i was talking about how instead of being
like i'm a cashier at mcdonald's you're
like i
process transactions for a fortune 500
company as well as being solely
responsible for the customer
experience and satisfaction and it's
like i don't
i don't i didn't change a light bulb i
single-handedly managed the successful
upgrade and deployment
of a new environmental illumination
system with zero cost overruns and zero
safety incidents
so it's it's about frames
um okay what up guys welcome to the just
probably things youtube channel today i
have a special guest
um ken and the reason i brought ken on
today is because i found out he is in
the 96th percentile of earners for
men his age so um he had a tic tac go
viral about how he
increased his salary 400 over six years
yep yeah in six years so he went from
making was it thirty thousand dollars
yeah thirty five thousand dollars to a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars
in the course of six years and i know a
lot of you guys are looking in
self-improvement you want to be the best
versions of yourself i have a lot of
young men that follow me on the channel
so i'm just here to pick his brain and
learn as much as i can
about how you did that i'm
happy to be here thanks for thanks for
having me
um love the pearly things big fan
been following your work ever since we
were thrown into a random instagram live
together
okay so um i wanted to just start from
like the begin like your college career
so
what did you study in college so i
went to emory university in atlanta
georgia
which it's a really good school but a
lot of people don't know of it because
it's more regional but it's usually
ranked in the top 25 somewhere between
ucla and berkeley so i double majored in
economics and history
which are both liberal arts degrees and
emory is really famous for its business
school
so i chose to not go into the business
school and pursue that avenue because i
interned for
a investment bank a small one in chicago
my freshman year
i think being a ceo of a company so that
he personally prefers to hire people
with a liberal arts degree because they
have a better range of experience that
they're exposed to in terms of their
classes as opposed to just being
marketing or just being consulting or
just being you know investment banking
which
like all very lucrative career paths but
doesn't really give you a lot of the
same opportunity
to move around and that's definitely
what i did throughout college i
you know worked at the investment bank i
worked in marketing i worked in research
and development and actual like
analytics and research and then i also
did sales and partnerships
so i think it just helped me get that
wider experience and how did you find
those
internships in college uh
so some of them are obviously like from
what the school's various websites are
but honestly
i use craigslist for a lot of stuff like
i got my first job out of college on
craigslist
um i just think like you have to use any
tools available to you and there's
obviously tons of resources that schools
have
for placements and stuff like that but i
think inherently i didn't have a great
gpa in college straight up i had a lot
of medical problems
um i know i mean you kind of touched on
briefly
so i was more focused on graduating in
four years than having a 4.0
and so that put me behind the curb on
competing against directly like the kids
in my class
so i had to come up with more creative
ways of even getting in front of people
for internships and sometimes you have
to farm your family and farm your
connections and find
contacts you might know um so i was
lucky on a few of those like my best
friend's dad was the head of hr fortune
500.
so that helped me get the marketing one
that was the most boring job i've ever
done in my life
someone said that took balls he could oh
shoot
i should not read that comment never
mind i remember
um wait so did you think it was helpful
to you
um having um going to such a prestige
like university did you do you think
that's necessary
in order to look like did you sorry do
you think that you could have
had the same career path even if you
went to a regular college
you cut out on me for a sec but i think
you asked me if i could have the same
career going to
not as good of a school and i think
absolutely um
i i think at the end of the day in my
opinion college just teaches you how
i don't unless you're like in a really
specific stem field with a really like
specific
technical degree college and getting a
college degree in my opinion is just
evidence that you have the ability to be
trained or to learn
so i think as long as you like show that
you're active and show that you have
hobbies or passions or interests outside
of like you know what your core major
was or whatever
you are an attractive candidate to
probably any
employer like it's not really like oh
cool this person like had
a 3 8 3 9 it's like what is who is this
person and like where do they fit into
this culture long term or
what have you that's like what like
places like google care about i think
more than exactly what your number is on
paper okay
um and what strategically did you do to
make yourself stand out
outside of like when you graduated
college what made you pick the first job
that you picked and why
so yeah like i said um i just
honestly when i graduated college i just
wasn't having success i think i was also
this would have had six years ago the
job market wasn't very great
at the time so i knew i wanted to be in
chicago
i was going through all the different
kinds of interviews and so it's a hard
balance between like
especially in your first job or first
couple of jobs being like i need a job
because i want to work first like i want
a job that actually i under
like stand to combine into a little bit
so
i wanted a job that at least like tied
to a few of my passions and so the first
job that i had was for a restaurant
database company that had purchased an
app called urban spoon that i actually
was a very avid user of
during my years atlanta so i had a
really like close personal
tie to it and that's why i initially
chose that job and then
uh for purposes of standing out i think
that like if you
if the job you're looking for is related
to something that you're like interested
in or passionate about you can probably
pretty easily speak to some part of that
in the interview process and show some
knowledge of like the industry or
your own expertise on something and that
will make you a stronger fan of it
so what
what were you doing like day to day
there typically
so there was like two parts to the job
and initially um
so what they did was they basically gave
you an area of chicago
and they said go walk into every single
restaurant in that area
um here's a list and get their menus get
their pictures
so basically it was i'm not sure if you
use yelp
at all the yelp is all user generated
content so that's like i go to
on yelp and i'm like oh their hours are
actually this or whatever
and so maybe the business does it but
yelp doesn't do that
so this is the motto creating a perfect
yelp listing for every seven
every one of the 17 000 restaurants in
chicago which means that they had to put
people on foot into all of those places
to get
pictures to get menus to like fill out
different features and stuff like that
so that was part one
and that was like some of that was
[ __ ] terrible because they literally
sent you to the hood
like what they sent me
this guy tyree and this guy whose name i
can't remember right now
to austin in the middle i look like it
was like 9 a.m
and people were like pantomiming like
shooting motions at us
like get out of there like
like some of the girls that were like on
at the company like
left crying from wherever they were put
that day like it was like it was like
some wild stuff anyway the second part
of the job in taking all of that
data that we had built and actually
putting it into a database basically
that data and then uh trying to figure
out how to
monetize it as we launched we never
actually got a chance to launch
really officially before they laid
everyone off which was october 15th
2015.
i'll never forget because it's like the
22nd so
i was unemployed on my birthday because
they did a layoff
as we were wearing company shirts that
day i still have the shirts
um wait so the one thing you said in the
tick tock that went viral
you said that you should not stay at a
job for more than two years
and when i heard this i thought it was
shocking because i've always been told
you have to show people that you're
loyal to a company
yeah i think that's an outdated old
school method
and all of the data will support me on
that statement
no longer really does anyone our age
does anyone even close to our generation
graduate work at one company for 20
years 40 years that's
gone you're not getting a gold watch at
your 50th
like at your retirement that's not how
it works because the data shows that if
you stay at a job every year you're
probably getting
a three to five percent raise and that's
only to combat inflation
maybe every two to three years you get a
10 raise which is like industry standard
for
within an organization to the next level
however if you leave your company
and go in a lateral position
realistically it raises somewhere
between
20 and 25 percent um there's a lot of
reasons
obviously for that and the reason that i
personally said to do it after
like 18 months to 24 months is because
at that point
you have a good understanding of what
your current role is you probably
already have a good amount of
achievements in there
realistically you probably stop learning
anything new
or like what i would always run into at
yelp at google and even now at walmart
is like you run
out of almost like things in your scope
in your area that you have
ownership of and maybe maybe this is
just true with bigger companies
startups obviously everything you're
wearing a lot of hats you're running
around
but i think there's pros and cons to
obviously both sides of this
yeah like she's saying down there like
prove yourself through grunt work
right that's why i worked at yelp for
close to two years i mean it's a
miserable sales job
but a lot of people start out their
careers there
because it shows that you have some form
of like ability to learn and get
experience
[Music]
so tell me how did you get a job at
google
that's like the um like nobody gets a
job at google
yeah you got a job at google and then
you left like that's crazy
twice
yeah um so i would say like my getting
into google was unique because they
approached me or i got i got reached out
to on linkedin
i think that was a combination of like i
had like i keep my linkedin very updated
i keep that very up to date i use all
the correct like
buzzwords business words if you anyone
watching this needs help
with that um go check out one salting
he's a good friend of mine he worked
for linkedin to stand out but i got
approached by
some headhunter recruiter who was hiring
for a new ad product that google was
launching
in the home service space and so working
at yelp
i was very familiar with that space uh
that was like our best sellers basically
and so i
i took the call from this guy and then
quickly realized that the product that
they were building out was gonna put
yelp out of business it was gonna put
home advisor and angie's list out of
business
and so when i realized i even had like a
small foot in the door
to google just through this like even as
a phone call i
would just decided i was not gonna let
anything stop me from getting as far
down the track with them as possible
so that went all the way to them being
like oh you're not in the bay area
we can't hire you because this is still
like a stealth mode startup
level org and we're only hired from the
bay because we don't have a relocation
budget and i was like well what if i pay
for my own flight out there for my
interview
in my own housing in my own relocation
like you guys don't have to do that
and i just fought down like every
objection they could possibly handle
that right everything that possibly
throw at me
it worked really well for me because
initially i was approached for a sales
job
and through my interview process i
showed up to the interview
my in-person interview that i paid for
my own plan to get out to pay for my own
airbnb all that stuff i showed up for
the interview and i felt something was
weird
so i went through the interview the
interview was fine but i could tell
something was off and i didn't
so two weeks after which as long as i
had heard not heard from them
i got to call that the position i had
interviewed for i've been filled
um and i was like you know that's a
bummer that's a huge bummer but hey i
did everything i could
and that's like i just i just don't want
to live with regrets on it like
google called me and showed some
interest i couldn't just let that go and
be like oh
you know five years from now what if i
had done that i would i wouldn't just
like
i can't live like that um so they were
like so we filled that position
however the team really likes you and
they are opening another position
on the operation side if you have any
experience with
sql and with like database stuff and i
told them very honestly i don't i was
just like have some good
i have some data experience um because
i'm salesforce certified through
like our leadership development program
but i'm like if you want sql i'll learn
i'll learn before i get there and i
guess that was good enough for them
uh so they took me for that position and
i showed up
a week and a half later uh to google
with
a book called how google works in two
sql certifications
um so what do i do for a living i see
that question keeps popping up
i manage advertiser support for
walmart.com so like walmart ecommerce
all advertisers on the website that's
like
pepsi craft foods coca-cola kimberly
clark
google dell computers every tv
every company that sells physical
products advertises on walmart
and i manage a team that supports all
their needs i'm a program manager
effectively so i build out like
getting the most problems on what are we
spending the most amount of time on what
can we optimize what can we automate
what available resources can we put
externally versus internally
to make things more efficient that's
pretty much what i do is i help
companies
scale primarily support systems um
without spending more money i did that
at walmart
it seems to work
how many hours do you work a week
usually 35 to 40.
really that's it yeah honestly at google
i worked like less at google i probably
worked 15.
really google was day camp google like
wasn't a real job
like i i hate saying that because it was
like
you know it's a dream job for a lot of
people
um but for me like working on operations
and stuff you almost work yourself out
of a job over time because you're only
given a certain scope that you're in
control of and unless leadership
is willing to give you a promotion or
give you more opportunity uh jay
hit me on linkedin my name's ken wax
it's really easy to find me
um but unless like you're willing to
able to get more projects more work you
effectively run out of stuff to do so i
was commuting
three and a half to four hours a day
to go to google's office and it was like
they have shuttles that take you the
shuttles have wi-fi
i have pictures of me sleeping on them
it's like it's really chill
but i would get down there i just didn't
have anything to do i'm like cool i did
like my little amounts of work
i'm going to the gym i'm eating all the
free food which is all awesome but i
didn't move to california to sit on
my hands like this like this is my these
are
these are the years before i have a
family i have kids where i'm really
trying to advance my career
so i needed to get a plate where i could
really do that which was like left
google to go to walmart which is very
much like what have you done for me
lately and
the biggest company in the world and
very old school
yeah and
what do you do um is what you were doing
at google and walmart similar sorry
you cut out ah i hate my wi-fi
um is what you were doing at google and
walmart um is that similar
they're yeah they're very similar
they're very comparable i think
actually at walmart i have more
ownership over it as like at google
i scaled the team of three account
managers to 20 account managers but i
wasn't their direct manager
but i didn't figure out like where they
spent all the time how can we make that
better
at walmart i directly manage a team of
six guys
and it's only six because i've made them
so efficient that even though we handle
500 percent or something like that more
businesses than we used to
the team is better it's more efficient
than they were when i took over
so it's like i train i manage and i
build all the systems i've established
like all of our baselines for
support for improvements like i'm also
very technical
now at least with like i'm not being an
engineer i'm just probably the second
most
technically knowledgeable person at
walmart on my product of the advertising
platform
so has walmart senior tech talks about
potentially wanting to leave
i've never said anything about wanting
to leave
i have never once said anything that i
want to leave
i said you said your next role you're
gonna be
shooting for 180 i never said when that
is also i
i feel like uh i i can't really do
walmart that dirty right now as they
yeah
you need paid medical leave and have
paid for 130
000 in medical bills in the last two
months
wow i i don't know if i owe them
anything necessarily
but actually i got a text today from one
of my friends on my team
that uh our director just quit she's
like everything's on fire
you should like bother me so maybe
so right now like i'm gonna paid medical
leave because my surgeries
i i don't have any plans on making moves
until
i'm at least like somewhat back to full
strength or whatever
it's not really on my purview
so i don't have so like if i was to
transfer that
i would probably end up taking like
somewhere like a 15 to 20
cut of my salary and i don't want to do
that yeah
i kind of want to push it as long as i
can
um okay so the next part of the
interview i really just wanted to ask
you about like
tips you have for young men that want to
get in the position you're in today
um because my audience is 95
male between the ages of like 18 and 35.
yeah so they just have a lot of
questions about how
how what choices you made young in order
to get to the position you're at today
all right
so i think there's a couple of things
that
really stand out and i think for me like
my first
serious job was a sales job right and
most jobs aren't
sales jobs but the one benefit that a
sales job has over a marketing job or a
consulting job or whatever is you have a
direct number
that you can point to and say that i'm
responsible for bringing x amount of
dollars to the company
here's what i contributed no one can
take that away from you it's like oh the
company did well it's like no i
single-handedly brought 250 000 and lost
quarters to company
so i think i take that mentality into my
other jobs and you can do that in
marketing you can do that in operations
you can do that in strategy
so i'm always trying to think about what
is the actual revenue impact
of like the work that i've done can i
measure that and is there any additional
revenue streams
that we could potentially have that
we're not currently utilizing
as well as like what is our so i work in
customer experience effectively now
right like i manage a customer
service to you even if like we're not
directly responsible for upselling those
customers
what is the value of that customer
yearly like
no one no one tracks this [ __ ] i do
i mean i've made these data points so
what does that person spend a year
what's the average lifetime
cost like keeping that customer so if i
can increase our retention rate by five
percent ten percent all of a sudden i
now could be like i just brought an
additional
five million dollar company anyway so i
think by cracking
that and thinking through things about
actually thinking about how
when you're going into your next
whatever you want to call annual review
whatever it is
what is the impact that you had no you
did your day-to-day task
what is the actual financial impact
could be like i want a 20 raise or i
want a promotion
what actual tangible evidence do you
have to support as to why you should
have that
uh is there what if you don't have the
numbers
to back it up is there a way to sell it
like you do
can you create it i mean depending on
like what you work in like i think you
can do
almost anything like i could make up i
could make up these numbers for
marketing i can make up these numbers
for
like obviously sales but like for any
part of an industry
or something i don't we should if chad
wants to throw me something i can
probably tell you how you can make your
number to be quantified
but right it's about measuring what the
impact is of
whatever as well as what makes you
different than other people in that same
role
um i don't live in california i now live
in chicago
i don't recommend speaking to a
financial advisor because they're taking
a cut of whatever you're doing max
that's your 401k contributions your
company should be matching three to six
percent
that way you're not paying a cut invest
in mutual funds you'll outperform the
market mutual funds get 10
to 11 returns annually cool
uh what did you just say i have no idea
what that means
mutual funds what's that so
if you went right now and bought
a hundred shares of apple stock right
you have risk now because apple well
despite the fact it's probably gonna go
up
could just crash tomorrow right right so
you diversify
your savings you diversify what you're
holding you diversify what you're
invested into and it's
called the diversity you lower your risk
level the more things you're invested in
the lower your risk is
right so mutual fund is i put a thousand
dollars
into a company that has 10 billion
dollars
and they have professionals investing on
that behalf so their risk levels are
incredibly low because
now i'm buying into something i'm not
just like a thousand dollars
i'm getting a piece of this thing that's
much larger and so
there they have mitigated the risk so
much
mutual funds uh generally also censored
by professionals outperformed the market
pretty well
like 10 to 11 unexpected returns
on that and then uh do you know how
compound interest works we'll just go
full
economy um i use actually this is
embarrassing because i was an econ major
i just don't remember
oh you had a hundred thousand dollars
you got 11 return
so now you have 111 000
then you get another 11 return now it's
100 like 25
000 and then it just keeps building on
top of that right it's not 100
000 gets 11 you're not getting 11k every
year but what happens with that is every
six
so every dollar you invest when you're
younger is worth a lot more when you're
older
then so like saving money now pays off a
lot more than if you serve this
starts it wow so what you're saying
you're saying that mutual funds if
you're going to invest that's the way to
go
outside of a financial advisor any
company that you work at probably has a
401k matching program
through fidelity through merrill lynch
through each
they had they will have something and if
you take
money out of your pre-tax
holdings right your pre-tax paycheck it
goes in there they throw some money on
so you choose what your mutual
appointments
and you can do that based on when you
want to retire so
i think i have a goal retire date of
2055 i don't know i have two 401ks one
from yelp that i haven't rolled over
into
walmart yeah just to be completely
transparent my two 401ks
are probably worth somewhere between
sixty and seventy thousand dollars
just because they've been compounded
because i maxed out my contributions
because i don't think about them
like you're not supposed to think about
this money right i also have my own
personal like investment holdings and
stuff like that that i do on my own
um so yeah there's a lot of
ways i think it's it's harder when
you're younger because like these are
things that you have to do to set up
long-term financial success for yourself
but it's not always like financial
transparency is not always clear
like i'm lucky that i have a dad who's
really smart who
started out with nothing and was like
flat broke as a kid and now he's got
you know he's successful and all that
stuff he retired at like 50
right so that's who i get to learn from
so
a lot of people don't have that right
it's kind of crazy how many people don't
know any of these things
yeah that's that's what like um i think
the mayonnaise have you heard of the
immunosphere before
no what's that yeah um it's like men's
self-improvement and men's dating advice
is how i would call it but
in my opinion it started from a lot of
guys that didn't have like dads to teach
them a lot of this stuff
um so it's actually that's why i
actually wanted to do this topic was
because i think a lot of them
didn't really have that advice from you
know like a dad a lot of the time
yeah yeah i mean
i think that uh it's tough without like
significant
desire of self or whatever to really
rise that far above whatever station
you're kind of
born into and that sucks right but
upward mobility in society is kind of
tough depending on where you start on
that
theoretical ladder so in
my opinion so
what other advice do you have in terms
of salary negotiations so
you always want to show them the roi is
what i gathered from the first one so
always put numbers behind it when you're
coming into your
either raised meeting or an interview
right i don't think you bring that to an
interview
necessarily i mean you can have that as
like bullet points on your resume and
you can talk through that as like to
tell me about yourself
but when it comes to an actual like if
you're interviewing like what is the
number that you're gonna say when they
ask you what are your salary
expectations
there's a couple of things you should
have done prior to that conversation
prior to even getting out that question
the first thing is to have gone online
and done some research
and you'll pretty quickly find out
either from class or any other site like
what people for that position in that
area like i just came from san francisco
right so obviously the salary for a
position in chicago is getting
significantly less than that position in
san francisco
but let's say let's say the range is
called sixty thousand to a hundred
thousand that's what i see online
right i am not going to tell them that i
am interested in 60 000 to 100 000
because they're always going to give you
the 60 000.
that's dumb so what you should always do
is you should set yourself to the higher
end of that spectrum
let's start it with the number that
you're comfortable with so in reality
the number that you're really going to
be happy with is like
70 000 you can say
70 to you know 90 000
so the minimum number that you're saying
is the number that you are happy to
accept
to some extent and obviously there's a
conversation to be had in there about
are we talking about salary versus total
compensations that include bonuses does
complete stock
rsus all those things that larger
companies can offer
but the other thing is you have to be
especially people that are like newer to
a job search or like just fresh out of
college i think there's a tendency that
they fall in love with like the first
job that comes at them
company has to sell youtube like
interviews are supposed to work
both ways but a lot of times we feel
like that company has the leverage
right because they're the ones that kind
of decide that
um so i think maybe just like i'm you
know six
six and a half years into my career at
this point like i feel power
when i'm in an interview i do like i'm
not just like
i'm not just like sitting there like oh
my god like yeah i would do anything to
work with this company like no i would
take like a 25
pay cut i just like someone like no
like you got to be able to like walk
away from them as well like sorry it's
not a good fit
right like it's supposed to be a
conversation but i think it's like
making sure that you're
quick like that question you have
yourself set to a point where you're
already comfortable
and then they'll very tell you what
they're not oh
british that's not on our way i know i
made a tick tock about the fact that
you stand up that's too high you will be
removed from
consideration and that's true
it is true um regardless of like what
they say
um they're not like i've talked to
enough recruiters and interviewers like
off camera that have like confirmed that
but you should always choose a number
that you're comfortable with and then
at that point you've already done to
tell me about yourself things so they
should know the value that you can bring
to an organization
like if you do the past present future
model you've already talked through what
the things are that you can
you have contributed and the numbers and
impact of your patented criminal
i always try to talk about like what i'm
imagining to be like the issues facing
that company and how i can like solve
for some of them really some of the
ideas that i already have
so in their mind they already have an
idea about what the potential value that
i'm going to be bringing to them is
and then that way if i ask for a number
it's just a fraction of what i'm
bringing about right
um could you talk more about the past
present and future model
yeah uh i did tick-tock on it
but past present future is just like the
this is just the classic like way to
handle the tell me about yourself
question that you're gonna be asked in
any interview in the past like
you walk through i always start with
like my education like i graduated from
emory university
with a dual major in econ history and
then i go through like the beginning of
my experience and like work my way up
making sure to kind of hit the most
important maybe bullet point or two
at each of those places for whatever the
position that i'm currently interviewing
for
is without me like overly being like
this is why i want this job but like you
know at this place
i learned how to pull data out of a crm
system and learn how to like
make things 50 more efficient then the
next one is like
i developed the csat and nps score and
you kind of you're stacking those up
into the present where it's like i'm
currently looking for
you know an opportunity that gives me
more up over
the teacher of a team and then the
future being like i think that i'm a
good fit for
this role in this company because i
think i would get to have that impact
here or whatever like your kind of spiel
is but you start you start with your
education
your background the past the president
has to like why you're currently on this
job search in the future it's like wow
and why you see yourself there for the
future
sorry i think i cut out for a second but
i i heard the end
um so what other interview tips do you
have for guys um looking to negotiate
salaries is there anything else that you
wanted to talk about or comes to mind
i'm a stalker hi
um and i'll openly like call that out in
my interviews or whatever and so i think
it's important to always have like
your research done right so i'll have
every all like notes
on people who are interviewing me
because especially like larger companies
it's not just like
oh yeah like i talked to a recruiter and
then i talked to a hiring manager and
then i got an offer you're going to feel
like a panel
you're going through a lot of different
people that you have to sell a lot of
different value to
because they're interviewing you for
different parts of the job potentially
and how you interact with those teams
so i think having like really strong
points to all of
obviously like what they care about is
also i would try to find like personal
connections to whatever it's like oh
yeah like i saw you've been there for
five years like or like
i talked to the vp of support for a
major company and i was like what is
your support strategy because i want to
be year 10
and i want your job
and i i think like when you also
position yourself that like you're
interested in i know i've literally made
a tick tock where i'm like move every
eighteen months to twenty four
don't take jobs planning i'm leaving i
take jobs wanting to be there long term
that i end up having to leave or want to
leave because of like other things
but i think if you like you know you
said that you're interested in like
growing with that company and you want
to be there for
a long long time they're more likely to
be invested in you long term right which
means they're more likely to be invested
up front as well um
so i think that um also
you can't always negotiate salary like
they send you an
offer you can negotiate it probably
within to like
10 to 15 i would say whatever ends up
hitting your desk now
it's a lot easier so based on you to
offer you can always
just say like i want 10 to 15 more
well if you know like i told them i'm
interested like i want a
salary or like the salary that i'm
looking recording is 100 to 120 000
dollars
whatever and they drop me an offer 90.
like this is not this is not what we
talked about yeah
right and then they're gonna like a lot
of places you're gonna try to do that
they're gonna be like well
you know we have a bonus structure and
we have
stock options or whatever and it's like
great
we have a commission thing i can't pay
rent with commission that i don't have
yet yeah
i remember they do that in sales a lot
actually i have a story about that so um
after i left
after zamotto laid everyone off i was
interviewing the two companies
uh yelp and some other place i can't
remember the name of right now but
they're
late headquartered in like missouri or
something like that and so i ended up
getting an offer from both companies
yelp had a 35 000 base plus commission
the other company had a 28 000
base plus commission but the commission
structure was better and so i went to
that company and i was like yo like
i can't take your offer it's too low
like you need to raise your base salary
35 000 for me to consider this
offer and they're like well we're mostly
a commission-based company
like you know the salary is actually
just a crutch until you ramp up on your
commission
i'm just like straight up you are not
competitive to other people in this
industry currently to other offers that
i have received
it's like a crutch will not pay my will
not pay my rent in the interim as i ramp
up
and so i think that's another part of
like salary negotiation is the fact that
like you can pretty quickly call out to
a company if the offer that they're
giving you is below market value
because you'll be able to find that
information
pretty quickly that's some that's a
leverage point i used
they actually raised that offer to match
the other one so they raised it
20 percent um and i think probably
changed their policy
off that but that's something i actually
just did over at
walmart i haven't gone back to work to
actually take it yet but i
actually got a 15 promotion um
after they told me i wouldn't get one
because i told them that i would resign
at the end at the end of june if i
i got both so you talk about how to
negotiate
it's being it's like you have to be you
have to honestly have to be able to walk
away
yeah that's what i was about to say
that's what's really been consistent
throughout your whole
career experience is you got balls like
you are not afraid
to leave um i try not to burn bridges
yeah but i think it's yeah i mean it's
important because otherwise not not just
like do not actually
stand by what you mean but you're not
going to have the confidence in that
delivery
or whatever i'm obviously very lucky
that i have like
a support system and all that stuff but
when i so like what happened to me was
like
back in february i had my annual review
and i was like i want fully remote i'm
like i either want to raise or i want
fully remote
and i went in there i didn't get either
um my manager's not the best but that's
fine
um so i was like pretty pretty bummed
about it
obviously and so but then i was like
okay well like what can i actually do
right now to potentially get myself
either one of those things and so i
started like leveraging
working myself to moving towards a
different team that would actually get
me that promotion
or if i had just like you know like
throwing a hissy fit and quit or
whatever
at that time because i didn't get that
like doesn't help me at all right
or it's like if i got defeated about it
it's like whatever it's like how can you
come up with a solution to the problem
so um i ended up
well now like i've moved to a different
team still under my same director my
director's at home it's great
um but i told him because he was like
yeah i'm sorry we didn't get you
remote like i thought it's done that
didn't get approved you know walmart's
just like an old-school company with
that stuff and i'm just like
yeah and i get that and i get that
you're not the one who made that
decision i'm gonna tell you right now
that you're going to lose talent
because of it i'm like not just me like
other people are going to quit too i'm
like i actually know people who are
going to leave the company
because you have this outdated policy
and he's like well yeah speaking of that
like since we don't really we never came
to a resolution
yeah we were supposed to go back to the
office in like july or whatever
one we're not going back july that's
just not happening let's just pull this
slide
and i'm like maybe trying to make me go
back to the office and i don't look her
anymore and i'll resign
i'm just like that's a bummer because i
like working here and i like the team
and i like what i built and i'm proud of
my accomplishments
and i'm like all right like if that's
just like what the policy is going to be
that's not going to work i'm sorry okay
and then all of a sudden he's like whoa
whoa whoa whoa hold on hold on we can
we can we can probably work something
out so now i'm fully remote
so you did a good job because you didn't
take it personal you didn't make it
personal at all you didn't get mad you
just said it wasn't gonna work
that's like i was lucky to learn that
from my first [ __ ] job when they laid
everyone off
nothing is personal but there is no
loyalty
that company does not have loyalty to
you nor should you have like
loyalty to that company you should not
be working like
80 hour weeks but only getting paid 40
hours
like yeah that's that's not that's not
it and like i think a lot of companies
really take advantage of younger people
and really get them to suck in and buy
into some culture they're like we're a
family
like we work hard no yeah is the ceo
working that hard
is your director working that 80 hours
with you
or are you doing that work at the bottom
in the dark i remember i used to
close down the yelp office i would be
there until nine at night i'm the only
[ __ ] person there
my manager's not there i'm closing deals
who's
this is me by myself who's who's got my
back right now yeah
who cares like and no that's how i felt
sorry go ahead i know and the last thing
i was gonna say to that is like
i i said it like my entire team like
google got laid off like i was gone at
that point
but my entire team got laid off because
they started the vendor company in
michigan that would do the work at a
third of the cost
so they could replace them there is no
loyalty
like we will always try to find a way to
do it cheaper so i get to work in an
interesting
part of any organization where i
literally
have to pay me to do it so i sell the
calorie i command
is the access point for them to save
millions of dollars
because they don't have to scale
organizations
my team should be three times the size
that it is but because i've made them so
efficient because i
manage the data and leverage whatever
our system so well
we still have the same amount of people
and we're more efficient for it
so the salary i command is because of
the fact that i can like then be like i
can save you these millions of dollars
which is why i want to race
um thank you to jade bones in the chat
for the donation
um someone asked the manosphere let me
write it down
oh gosh he's blue pill guys if you know
you know
yeah what
no it's um you know the matrix there's
the red pill and there's the blue pill
yeah yeah so if you enter the man
i don't i haven't seen the movie i'm not
gonna lie
um accepting a job that isn't what you
want and
yeah so that's another thing too with
accepting a job
as well as like for negotiating your
salary after you accept a job
especially if you accept a job you start
working that job and the roles and
responsibilities of set job change
it does not match what your job
description is
track it like i always think it's
important to have a copy of what your
job description was
like i can't tell you walmart did this
to me i started the job
and they couldn't give me a job
description so they finally gave me a
job description it's not
all for the role that i interviewed for
it's not all what the role and
responsibilities are that i started
working and so by the time i got to my
first
whatever you want to call an annual
review
i had that i'd like here's what i do
here's my roles and responsibilities and
here's what i was told my roles and
responsibilities are
going to be because i now handle like so
much stuff outside of the scope that i
was
told like i need more compensation or i
think it's fair to
like to ask for more
you never say [ __ ] like i do the work of
two people steve quit and i have to take
on their stuff
they don't want that but it's about it's
about like how you
are growing to whatever and so like how
you have taken on these new
roles and responsibilities because
you're a go-getter right because you've
seeked out that responsibility
but it is fair to be compensated for it
um what books do you recommend for
interviews and competing in the current
job market
i don't know if i have books for
that i read books about general business
more than every books about
interviewing um
[Music]
i can get back to you on that but yeah
that's
those aren't the best resources that i'd
probably recommend
for that as opposed to books is i would
recommend like i mentioned before
um my friend and former google becca
jonathan javier
at wong sultan which is a company
um that he's the ceo of tons of free
resources
so many free resources online how to
stand out how to get referrals for
companies as opposed to oh he has like a
master class and all that stuff but most
of his resources are free
how to get referrals what percent of
like jobs actually come from referrals
how it helps you
like stand out as opposed to just
hitting the quick apply button on
linkedin where you're throwing your
resume to the hole
and all of that so he's great i'll
actually be talking with him on
a podcast or something on friday he
asked me to
come on but he's great um and then
i'm gonna i'm gonna plug my
ex-girlfriend because she has good
confidence
so uh that that would be kristin on tick
tock or career ticker career kristin on
instagram both good resources
uh one insulting and career person
highly recommend
would you ever consider writing a book
i don't know if i would yeah i'd write
like my memoirs but then i'd be
worried i'd have to like change my name
because of the amount of illegal [ __ ]
that i've done along the way
i meant i meant about um salary
negotiations
or a course yeah um
i'll look into it lord knows i have some
time right now uh my dad's written a few
books so maybe i could leverage him for
that my dad wrote a book on corporate
murders and acquisition so i could
probably write one
on like how to leverage and negotiate
yourself
um yeah that'd be interesting i should
probably take some more classes on it
yeah there's there's been a couple
comments asking if you had a course or a
book they could buy
yeah i i don't know maybe it's imposter
syndrome
or whatever because like coming from san
francisco
sure i i just also know so many people
who are doing better than
me too you know but that's the thing too
is you should always be leveraging that
you should be surrounding yourself with
people who are more successful than you
because if you believe the added you are
the
average of the five people you spend
time with you don't want any of those
people to be
like people that are necessarily
bringing it down or not bringing some
kind of like knowledge
yeah that's really good advice um let's
see if there are any more questions in
the chat
is there any other um because we i try
to close it out in about an hour
so is there any other advice you have
for anyone else anything else you wanted
to talk about
um i think like what i was wondering
what this was i was curious
as to like where most people
they're located i mean like what
industries that they work in because
i think if like you're younger and
you're trying to quickly
command a high salary i would recommend
obviously working in tech
or like technological it's fields
and you can do that without having a
tech degree like i said i have an econ
degree or like a history
there's for every technical job there's
like three support jobs that are not and
i don't mean the customer support but
there are
jobs that every company has that
supports that be that like being an
accounting executive on microsoft to
sell
their products or whatever like you
don't need to have a technical degree to
be in a technical
company and um i think the upwards
mobility at tech companies is much
larger
than like companies that are not in the
tech sphere if you're trying to get that
upper mobility
like i highlighted moving every 18 to 24
months
no company i've ever interviewed at has
ever
asked me why i moved companies so much
why i
papa it's never even a question um
reading the chat that's great
but as long as like i think
yeah that making sure that you're
continuing to like write down what the
um impact that you have at your
companies are like you won't remember
that
like if you get to give it something at
the beginning of the year by the end of
the year you're not going to remember
what you worked on what the impact was
you're trying to think accurate you're
not going to have it you want to write
all that down you'll actually end up
really impressing yourself
and if your current company doesn't
appreciate it you know what you're who
will your competitor
yeah and your competitor will always pay
you more for the skills not for your
knowledge necessarily
of like how the company works like
amazon's not going to pay me more
because i work at walmart because i call
merchants
amazon give me more because why would i
leave my current role for you
to build your stuff yeah
but after like a year and a half to two
years you can pretty quickly i think
like prove your value
as to like why you should get a
promotion somewhere else
no i think that's really great advice um
would you ever consider
um quitting in order to start a company
yes and no um i think i tried to do that
actually at one point when i worked at
google and i quickly realized how
expensive starting a company is
especially in tech
because um yeah i was trying to i was
trying to like come up with something
that
the end goal would probably have been
like to be bought by linkedin or some
kind of integration linkedin
but to even just get through getting an
engineer to get a minimum viable product
up to
getting a legal team to run through the
ip stuff to make sure there's not
something out in the market already or
make sure it's not a patent sitting on
something
you need capital you need like some
significant capital now there's the
other side of the coin which is just
like
go [ __ ] make it and go do it and
unless someone like sues you
keep going and if someone sues you keep
going because that means you're doing it
better than they are
mm-hmm dude i had some dude at
um the airport in tel aviv give me that
advice he's like
don't make it and if someone sues you
for it because they did it first
they're just jealous and
it's like yeah so i'm actually
considering that as i'm continuing to be
on medical leave i think at this point
i've been on leave for
eight weeks and i get another 11. okay
if i so choose so i have a lot of time
on my hands
i'm trying to learn how to use
adequately and so
um learn
or to be more like product company as
opposed to like a service company
i don't want to necessarily like i don't
know i'm starting to give out free
career advice not just here but like i
open slots on my
calendy and my link tree on tick tock so
you can put 30 minute slots with me now
to like i'll review your resume and help
you like make it better
or like whatever your career goals are
i'll talk to you about it and i'll
probably point you in a direction or i
can connect you to somebody
um yeah i just kind of want to pay it
back if i can get paid for that that'd
be sick
but i'm not sure if there's a company in
there yet yeah
do you want to tell them where to find
you
sure yeah all my plugs um
i am ken wax on linkedin i am at ken
on tik tok i am wax on myself on
instagram
uh it's just my last name um yeah
anything you need my
all my stuff is pretty clearly linked if
you need to get to all my stuff i just
go to my tick tock just go to ken
the easiest thing to do everything else
is linked there i have my
emails there my linkedin is there
everything's
probably the easiest way to get in touch
with me um
i respond to everything too i'm pretty
good
minus the really thirsty dms we don't we
don't answer those
okay eric you're trying to sell me
instagram followers that's not it
are you gonna retire in the u.s or
outside the u.s
um questions one at a lot of places i
have
the ability to live in multiple
locations so what i'm working on right
now
is waiting for the market to crash which
the housing market will probably crash
back into this year because the interest
rates on
borrowing money is going to go up which
means the mortgage market will
experience a massive plummet because
right now um
people are buying a book market value
because it's so easy to borrow money
um for their for their mortgages so by
the end of the year that'll change
and then i think the housing market will
experience a 20 decrease
15 20 percent and i think i'm going to
try to buy a place
in chicago permanently and then i want
to buy a place in socal
ideally as well um on the beach
would be would be the dream and then um
outside the u.s do i have passive income
is tick-tock passive income
yeah yeah
yeah so people think like you make so
much money on tick tock and like it's
it's
fun you can't
if you get a brand deal but that's i
made more from a brand deal than i did
from the creator fund in six months
yeah me too so
that that's something i don't know i'm
starting to try to think about doing
more
brand deals but i don't even care that
much about monetization of tick tock
uh do i have passive income no i have
side hustles though i just picked up a
side hustle
where i will if you need anyone to um be
a superhero at your child's birthday
party you can
hire me i can be captain america
what do you charge for that uh i don't
know the company charges necessarily
but yeah so my friend jion
works for he's like a model actor
from chicago and you're sure coming
called fairy tale my party
and like you can rent like i mean they
do like birthday parties they do parades
they do like celebrity parties all that
stuff
but i make 55 an hour doing it so you
annualize that that's 110 a year
but that's before tips as well so in
reality you're going to end up making
like
70 to 110 bucks for an hour that's not
bad
i'll take that um for like an
hour or two on a saturday sounds pretty
good
um so that's not really passive income
i have stocks i have i'm not going to
count tick tock
as passive income but i think to really
build up passive income you need to have
like
oh [ __ ] yeah no i'm working my amazon
merch my amazon merch page
you know about amazon merch pro so my
director at walmart put me on to this
basically you you know there's a million
t-shirts available for sale on amazon
so what you can do is you can basically
come up with a bunch of t-shirt designs
i kind of want like i'm gonna think i'm
gonna do with a bunch of like
random tik tok [ __ ] where you know like
sheesh and like
ice and veins kind of stuff like and
then it doesn't like you don't
hold inventory right you're basically
just
the art between amazon drop ship
on cat and so you can you'll basically
clear
a couple of dollars per sale amazon may
solve
money the t-shirt sells for 20 bucks so
you get three
or something like that but you have zero
inventory management you have to do
nothing wait so how much do you make off
of a 20
t-shirt you broke up for a second i can
make it's like three bucks or something
like that
okay like my director said he like made
a couple of shirts like
ages ago and now he makes like 5 600 a
month off but really
yeah so i actually have the merch page
open i should like
i actually need to get in touch with
them but i'm afraid to talk to anyone at
work because then they're going to be
like when are you coming back
and i kind of like kind of like my lost
existence currently where they don't
no one seems to care where i am any kind
of working at a really big company
right you are just a cog
yeah send me the link to that i'll link
it in the description
but thanks so much for taking the time
um i know you're super busy
um yeah now i do physical therapy
um i'm i'm gonna end this stream but
yeah guys do not forget to follow ken
on tick tock instagram um he's probably
gonna have a youtube page
soon so when he launches that i will put
it in the description
yeah that's the next great frontier was
it hard to launch a youtube page is
it's getting a big mic is that a set of
can you write that off as a small
business center cost is that a tax
deductible
probably probably um it was impossible
to learn though it took me like three
months but
yeah that'll be the official launch of
the kenergy brand
no that was something i was like working
on doing like last year
um actually before quarantine i started
trying to build out a whole website
because i do a lot of cooking stuff as
well
um i don't know if pearl and i would
work she would fluff around and dunk on
me i think she's probably got an inch on
me
in the next possible way but i don't
count everybody
bro if you want a workout partner i got
you we're not that far from each other
we're probably like
25 minutes oh yeah
so you ever want to go work out i'm down
slash i'm still working on
i don't know we'll hang out we got plans
we're fine we're hungry
okay well i will i will i'll probably
have you on again at some point so i'll
talk to you next time ken
thanks for coming on thank you for
having me thanks everyone thanks pearl